we're going to begin though with the
news that the omicron variant has been
detected here in america the first
confirmed case of the strain was found
in san francisco in a person who was
vaccinated but who has not gotten their
booster shot just yet so far only 21 of
eligible adults in this country have
been given the booster that leaves more
than 100 million vaccinated people who
have not received a booster and may have
declining immunity nancy cordes is at
the white house with the latest on the
government's response good morning to
you nancy
good morning gail the president is going
to be unveiling a new set of policies
today designed to help make things a
little smoother this winter a winter
that now features this unpredictable new
variant the plans are meant to reduce
the transmission of kovid and to bring
down the cost of at home testing
we'll fight this variant with science
and speed not chaos and confusion
starting early next week the biden
administration will require all
international air travelers to get
tested within one day of departure
instead of three it's relatively
straightforward we're prepared to
implement it as soon as they want us to
implement it
the administration will also extend mask
mandates on public transit through
mid-march it'll also launch family
vaccination clinics and require health
insurers to cover 100 percent of the
cost of at home coveted tests the new
measures come one day after the first
case connected to the new variant was
detected here in the u.s the sequence
was confirmed at the cdc
as being consistent with the omicron
variant the infected individual lives in
san francisco but returned from south
africa on november 22nd just a few days
before scientists there revealed the
existence of the new variant the
traveler tested positive a week later
the evidence that an individual with
omicron identified by sequencing
actually has mild symptoms is improving
i think is a testimony to the importance
of the vaccinations the cdc has directed
airlines to provide the names of any
passengers who traveled to the eight
southern african nations near where the
variant was first detected within the
past 14 days the california traveler was
vaccinated but did not have a booster
shot and u.s officials are mulling over
the possible necessity of an omicron
specific booster the administration has
been in contact with the pharmaceutical
companies to go ahead and take the steps
in case we need it but the mistake
people would make is to say let me wait
and see if we get one if you're eligible
for boosting get boosted right now
all u.s adults now eligible for a
booster if it's been six months since
that pfizer moderna vaccine now
scientists won't know whether the
omicron related booster is necessary
until they're able to study how
responsive the variant is to the current
batch of vaccines the president is
slated to announce all these new
policies at the national institutes of
health this afternoon vlad
all right nancy thank you very much